let's go to john sopple who spent years
at the bbc explaining american politics
to the uk
now he's here to explain british
politics to all of us uh john good
morning to you
if in fact boris johnson walks through
that front door and announces his
resignation what happens then
we don't know we have no idea what boris
johnson is going to say or what he's
going to try and do i cannot begin to
describe how surreal british politics
has become in the past 48 hours it's
kind of gone slightly monty pythons a
bit of scruffy downton abbey and a bit
of succession thrown in as well because
it has gone mad we have had a new
treasury secretary appointed on tuesday
night
on when the next morning he goes on a
round of the tv and radio studios to
defend boris johnson this morning he
issues a letter saying boris johnson has
got to go we get a new education
secretary appointed who has resigned
within 24 hours so what boris does or
says next is anyone's guess and i think
that what he will try to do
is he will try to hold on until the
autumn and he's apparently reappointing
ministers as we speak which seems
utterly bizarre
but whether he'll be allowed to remains
to be seen and the desperate thing that
the conservative party is worried about
is embroiling the queen in a row over
the constitutional succession of prime
minister yeah boris
there are many boris johnson quotes that
come to mind uh at a moment like this
one in particular his philosophy on
resignation he was asked about it back
in 2015 2016 and he said he preferred to
cello tape everything together and kind
of shamble through so we'll see if that
is in fact going to happen uh dana i
hand it over to you i think that the
next question even though we may not
know when it seems to be the fate is
that resignation so who might be prime
minister next
you're going to wish you hadn't invited
me on the television this morning
i don't know there are so many
candidates i can i mean there are so
many cabinet ministers who are looking
themselves in the mirror and saying i
could be prime minister
they all think they've got to shout so i
think nadim zahawi who is this the the
treasury secretary chancellor of the
exchequer who's been appointed he'll
fancy himself the foreign secretary liz
trust she's cutting shorter trip to
indonesia at the g20 to come back early
i can go on with a list of runners and
riders but there is no standout
charismatic figure
in the way that boris johnson was
charismatic david cameron the former
prime minister described boris johnson
as as slippery to get hold of as a
greased piglet today he's been turned
into sausage meat
john um in one word what is born boris
johnson's legacy
brexit
chaos
and a bit of untrustworthiness
john soppel thank you